c'est une nouvelle étape vers un retour
à la normale à partir de demain vous
pourrez boire un verre jusqu'à 23h le
couvre-feu recul et la france ouvre
encore un peu plus jauge à 50% dans les
bars et restaurants 100 % en terrasse
65% dans les cinémas mais les plus
impatients se sont sans doute les
patrons de salles de sport
après sept mois de fermeture les tapis
de course tourne à nouveau le reportage
à tour de rémi carton à petites foulées
c'est l'heure des derniers réglages dans
cette salle de fitness de saint cyr sur
loire
après sept mois de fermeture les
salariés sont heureux de reprendre leurs
activités
c'était moi même en chômage partiel le
coach
la personne qui gère l'entretien c'est
un plaisir pour tout le monde de
retourner à une vie normale
désinfection des machines fléchage jauge
limitée à quelques sportifs le protocole
sanitaire et strictes pour retrouver le
chemin de la salle les adhérents vont
devoir prendre de nouvelles habitudes et
cela commence dès l'entrée le qr code
ici de l'application tout en tics au
vide et nous allons fortement incité les
adhérents à le scanner afin d'avoir un
contrôle des plus des plus complets
devant cette salle d'escaladé à
tours-nord l'équipe finalise quelques
travaux on n'a pas eu besoin fera pas
les grosses entreprises à l'équipe est
mobilisée et à être à fond pour la
réouverture sur les parois on s'entraîne
déjà escaladé avec un masque pour éviter
les contaminations les grimpeurs ont un
allié plutôt originale la magnésie
liquide une crème qui permit de mieux
agrippé des prises mais qui a aussi des
vertus désinfectantes
donc on a à peu près à 75% le degré
d'alcool sur ce type de magnésie si vous
prenez de vraiment protégé à vos mains
quand vous touchez les parois dans cette
salle de sport du vieux tours on est
optimiste sur la réouverture après de
longs mois anxiogène de crise sanitaire
le personnel espère que les vertus
physiques et thérapeutique du sport
attireront de nouveaux clients
la boxe et des circuits que propose en
fait 103 nhs permettent de penser qu'à
soi qu'au sport et non à tout
a tout les anxiétés qu'on peut avoir
autour les sports de contact en
intérieur ne seront autorisées que le 30
juin en attendant cette date il ay ay si
tout ce qu'il faut pour reprendre le
rythme tout ce qui est coordination les
sacs pour que chacun puisse avoir son
sac et boxer seul sur sac
les rameurs boxer en gardant ses
distances a deux avantages éviter de se
contaminer et de finir ko